is it true that jamie lee curtis is
playing you in a lifetime movie
it's true it's true were you pinching
yourself that she wants to play you
i still do i still do sarah cunningham's
story
is one for the movies she's the founder
of free mom hugs
a coalition empowering the world to
celebrate the lgbtq plus community
through visibility and education maybe
you can walk us through your journey
from church to pride parades how did
your work within and for
the lgbtq plus community begin it began
when our youngest child came out
and i didn't take the news very well at
all i reacted badly and i heard him
and uh the process of coming from the
church to the pride parade and getting
involved with this beautiful community
and hearing stories from the community
is what really prompted everything
in 2014 my husband and i stood with our
youngest son at the oklahoma city pride
festival and that was my first
intentional
interaction with the gay community and
in 2015 i made a homemade button
that read free mom hugs and with anyone
who made eye contact with me i would say
could i offer you
a free mom hug and the first hug went to
a beautiful young girl who said it had
been four years since she got a hug from
her mother
because she's gay and that spark
lit a fire and i'm not the first mom to
offer free mom hugs
but from that experience we started the
non-profit free mom hugs
obviously june is pride month what does
pride mean to you and has that
evolved over the years especially as you
attend more
pride events as an ally i consider pride
a time where we can
stand by and support those who don't
have to hide or be ashamed of themselves
anymore
and then as a mother i have to
acknowledge that pride paved the way for
my son
that was my first glimmer of his
authentic self was at an
oklahoma city pride festival so i
appreciate it i think it's important to
recognize it as an important part of our
history
and our future speaking of future is it
true that jamie lee curtis is playing
you in a lifetime movie
it's true it's true and she found out
about a book that i wrote
um how we sleep at night a mother's
memoir
and she read the book and she loved it
and she acquired the rights to it
and we've got the green light we're just
waiting on time when you finally met
jamie lee curtis what was that
interaction like were you pinching
yourself that she wants to play you
i still do i still do she's just very
if you've been able to spend any time
with her you know she's just very
sincere
very um intuitive she's a woman of
integrity so i have every confidence
that she'll be able to tell the story
and tell it well